special thanks to our friends at
cerebral for sponsoring today's video
cerebral is a mental health platform
that provides access to ongoing online
prescription medication management
counseling and therapy for anxiety
depression insomnia and other conditions
all for a flat monthly rate treatment
for adhd bipolar and ptsd are available
in certain states what's great about
cerebral is it allows you to visit with
your provider therapist or care
counselor online and from the comfort of
your own home and it's designed for
comprehensive care and long-term
treatment something you just don't see
everywhere else cerebral can cost three
times less than traditional therapy
services and to start
all you need to do is fill out a short
survey and answer a few questions and
choose the plan that's best for you so
if you'd like to take the next step in
working on your mental health click the
link in the description below and start
the questionnaire and get connected with
a provider right away your first month
starts at only thirty dollars
[Music]
chuck what's up why'd you call this
emergency meeting of our explainer video
well here's the deal
what is the deal with football-shaped
planets
dad i saw this thing and i was just like
i gotta know what's up with a football
[ __ ] player well it's it's playoff
season so of course
you're gonna find
right now
it's the january going into february oh
yeah so of course we're going to find
footballs in space yeah now now if it
was tom brady planet it'd be a squishy
football oh
couldn't help you you can't let that go
for the eagles man
so here's the thing uh so first of all
i have to be accurate and say
the the the planet was less like a
football
and more like a rugby ball okay just to
be clear oh god only you would say that
i'm just being precise excuse me okay
all right i got what you're saying
excuse me okay as i speak
we are rising through 4
900 exoplanets
known in the universe planets orbiting
other stars
and in the year 1995
that number was zero
right
right so if you count it up it's you
know
which is it a couple a week i mean how
many weeks is that it's 52 times 10 uh
at 500 times
you know we're
discovering them at a beautiful rate so
that the next the next thing is when we
get wormhole travel to other stars yeah
we can rank them in sequence where those
that have exoplanets so we can just do
that right because
that's where you want to go
like you don't yeah it's a destination
you can't just visit a star yeah you
don't want to just go see a star you
know we could do that in hollywood so
here's the deal
if a planet orbits very close to its
host star
the tidal forces can be extreme
and just to remind you about tidal
forces it's a fancy name but it's very
simple if one side of you is closer to
the source of gravity than the other
side of you
that's true for all of us at any given
time but if it's severe that difference
in gravity will stretch you in that
direction
sweet well you know it stretches not the
right it will elongate you right right
in the direction of the object that has
this gravity operating on your physical
body
and we talk we talk about the moon and
the earth oceanic tides it stretches
them
and we see this as water sloshing in and
on and off the the shores
even though we are rotating into the
tidal bulge we we're very
human-centric on everything we see and
think and we think the water is coming
back and forth to us but as we said in a
previous explainer we are rotating into
the tidal bulge of the earth it turns
out
that some planets could can be
much more liquid and gaseous than earth
is okay and liquid and gas are more
responsive to tidal forces than the
solid object than solid objects are
you'll you know earth does distort
according to the moon's ties but not as
much as you see from the tides because
we're solid it's just harder to elongate
solids but when you are liquid and
gaseous you are very susceptible
and so we found a plan you're no fun at
a party
why when you're liquid and gaseous
why
oh if you're gonna make me say it okay
oh sorry okay fine
so okay so these exoplanets that are not
fun at parties um there's one that was
discovered in particular and you know
how they discovered it it eclipsed it
moving it moved in front of the host
star you can't see the planet it's true
let me say it let me say it it transited
the whole star nice i learned that from
you my friend nice
nice so transit means it comes in front
of it and so that's how we knew there
was a planet there at all because the
light from the main star dimmed by just
a little bit okay and then came back up
while the planet was moving
between us in the line of sight okay
so now it's so it's not like an eclipse
where the whole thing is blotted out
it's just a tiny bit but that's how it
was discovered so now watch what happens
if the planet were spherical
you can model what that looks like as it
begins to cover
its little bit of the surface of the
star but if it has an elongated shape
then as it comes on to the star we're
going to see it at an angle and it's
going to be it's going to be it the the
curve of light will have a different
shape than it would if it were a perfect
circle coming across
so they did a careful analysis of what
the shape of the drop in the light of
the host star does and from that
analysis they concluded that this object
is elongated in the direction of the
star
on a level like it's like it's a rugby
ball that's really cool so now from that
is there anything you can deduce about
the planet like you said if you're a
gaseous and liquid you're more prone to
you know be susceptible to these uh
tidal forces or is it just the proximity
to this thing with very you know
large gravity pull
well so here's the thing so you might be
it could there be life there well if
there's any place where there's liquid
water we find teaming with life on earth
so and nasa is guided by the search for
water in all it does in the solar system
right okay the moons of icy moons of
jupiter and saturn and and so water is a
big deal and so here's the problem when
you were tidily shaped like that you
were also tidally locked
tidally locked
oh i just learned i don't mean to brag
or anything
i just learned that i was a clue on
jeopardy
really yes
and that clue was okay this person
uh this person
in high school
invented a wrestling move called the
double title lock
that made it up to jeopardy that's
you knew this about me but i didn't know
like jeopardy knew it i mean that i
thought that was just our secret
um
yeah uh that is the question that got
many people to lose a lot of money
[Laughter]
now if they said wait if they had asked
a question like this this astrophysicist
because that i mean if you say
astrophysicist to most people in america
they're going to give your name period
they're going to give either they're
going to give your name or they're going
to give carl sagan that's it you can
look at carl sagan and know the only
thing he ever wrestled with was
questions from the universe
built billions of billions of billions
of questions right but yeah that's how
they should have asked it otherwise you
know you kind of you know dangling out
there yeah
they might have said this scientist i
have to check check the words but anyhow
the planet is surely tidally locked
to the sun which to its star which means
it's only showing one face
and it's the elongated side of the face
and so so the the planet
will uh
how can i describe this for everyone
just listening so this football this
this rugby ball is always pointing
towards the host star as it orbits it
right wow
so you see that you see it
moving around always keeping its
alignment to the host star so that's a
tidal lock here's a problem if you're on
that planet and you're on the side
that's facing the star that's gonna get
hot
right and if you're on the side on the
opposite side it's gonna get cold
because you'll never see sunlight
because that is literally
where the sun don't shine so
um it's hard to imagine how life could
be sustained under such extremes the
fact that we rotate is a force of equal
it's an equalizing force in the
temperatures on the earth it's like
cooking a chicken on over an open fire a
rotisserie you got it you can't leave it
if the rotisserie starts rotating you
will burn one side of the chicken that's
right yeah that's there it is
that's great i'm hungry
[Laughter]
anyway so that's our football planet
and with this new technique they'll
probably find many more such football
planets so we can look forward to that
as the exoplanet count continues to rise
above four thousand nine hundred
but it'll be five thousand hits five
thousand we'll do a special explainer
just celebrating uh that moment cool
and by the way let me say it again i've
said it many times but let it be clear
uh if you were born in 1995 onward
you have only known a world
that has exoplanets
wow so i will
knight you that generation generation x
so planet wow look at that i see what
you just did you see what i did you see
what i did and by the way i'm gonna say
if you were born from 1995 on
you don't know anything
you're you're a bunch of like
idiots okay
and social media sucks all right
your generation is a waste
[Laughter]
guys do not get off my lawn these are
right and get off my lawn
okay before chuck embarrasses himself
further with half our audience this has
been a star talk explainer just trying
to understand football exoplanets
all right chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure until we meet again
keep looking up
[Music]